aha here we go me suddenly gasps hey
okay oh yes got new ideas yeah
what is he going to do here play the
play the pun off really he's playing the
pan off okay let's see how he handles
this
[Music]
oh the sideline but how does that work
again
I don't remember I really don't remember
94 Bishop e6 okay that was a bit too
long yeah Bishop g5 is not regarded as
critical but I simply couldn't remember
of course yeah
directly trying to trade everything down
yeah but white is probably a little bit
better if I take it's difficult not to
to be honest
okay if I go a six that could weaken
could be a weakening of my queen side
which is hard not to play this in the
long run
check
the set dangerous it looks completely
harmless
I came let's block this for the moment
maybe has a little something which often
is enough of course
still I have a hard time to believe I
should be with him because my king is
near the action and his king is not
yeah okay this is this is so nice him
I've got this pawn on c4 to play against
my king is playing so like it's just a
bit better maybe maybe it's that's
something that white can hold but it's
not fun so yeah just rook c8 okay one
muxu form it's probably it probably
still a draw I wonder is there some way
to play for win
mmm oopsie 8 it's a bit lame it's a bit
lame to be a to before maybe somehow I
don't see much better bouquet one now
[Music]
rooty one okay
check
yeah I've got four against three but
it's not going to be enough usually
check so let's see Scott age five in so
there are very little ideas here
not threatening anything after you have
to say a promise there is not much that
you can do really
you can try G fire but it's also usually
just going to be be a draw still once
White has got H fine it's really very
little to to play for him I can try this
check time warning King King do 693 it's
a draw anyway it's really not much to do
check some e to okay ain't not ready
are they doing your plane is on time or
what yeah he honestly just tries to play
this on time now what is what a [ __ ]
yeah this is since it's just the biggest
idiot ever yeah this guy check check
check check check check check check
check check check check check check
check check check check check check
check
check check check check check check
I really wonder what the point is you
know I know I actually get through
trading maybe I would have one on time
against this [ __ ] idiot ready this is
such an a come on I really don't know
what this is
in places like a complete [ __ ] yet from
its he just goes all the way and then he
tries to win this look again look on
time yeah yeah anyway yeah the thing is
um of course I'm I'm a bit better here
because my King is playing but it's
maybe not possible to win maybe not and
I get b5 him home I didn't consider that
that's the engine suggestion and okay
those points they are not going anywhere
soon and this is dangerous now I didn't
think about that I mean what I did was
always giving me a bit of an advantage
but it's maybe not enough to win that's
really the case yeah yeah this is this
is possible maybe it's a little bit of a
better a better version but it's still
four against three years a draw and he
can basically always get that by
dropping this engine just holding the
position yeah and as usual he he played
the the most simplistic way in d5 yeah I
mean you should would have expect this
with white being better just making
pressure with the better structure and
everything but it rather trades
everything Jack Jack to a worse ending
Joe
it's a bit of a shame that I couldn't
get more and then wrong again 3 out of
it
maybe yeah that's not really good
working I mean this is interesting to to
prevent him to play each form but he has
the six zone that doesn't really work as
well and I think it's extremely I mean
what kind of person do you have to be to
play such a game and then try to win
this position on time I mean this is
this is absolutely crazy if in my book
and not taking only have to happy to
have a draw after this crap game no you
have to play this on anyway so that was
moved 69 and at the end we were so I
would have easily made the fifty-fifty
moves maybe I should have tried actually
because I'm a and I'm the quicker player
if I want to be and anyway come on let's
scratches this this games are always an
annoyance no matter how they have they
are playing out thanks for watching